in 2013 Barton Gellman of the Washington
Post started publishing stories about
what he called the surveillance
industrial state that were based on
documents given to him by former
National Security Agency contractor
Edward Snowden along with the work of
filmmaker Laura Poitras and journalist
Glenn Greenwald gell-mann's exposes laid
bare and extensive and previously
unacknowledged network by which the
federal government systematically and
illegally spied on American citizens and
routinely circumvented checks on its
power Gelman has just published Dark
Mirror Edward Snowden and the American
surveillance state which tells the story
of his interactions with the
whistleblower bureaucrats politicians
and the media as he helped reveal one of
the biggest secrets in US history
I spoke with Gelman about his new book
and his earlier Pulitzer prize-winning
work detailing the ways in which Donald
Rumsfeld Dick Cheney and others in the
Bush administration exceeded
constitutional limits in the name of
prosecuting the war on terror Barton
Gellman thanks for talking to Reason
allows you to be here let's start by
discussing the title of your book and
you know in many ways the controlling
metaphor for what you're talking about
here Dark Mirror explain the
significance of that term the idea comes
down to this we're living in a world
that is that is akin to those police
interrogation rooms where the Watchers
on the outside can see very clearly
what's happening inside the room the
person inside is completely transparent
to his observers of while at the same
time that person inside the room can't
see out the mirrors opaque on that side
and we're all living inside that
interrogate interrogation room in some
ways because the government has built a
surveillance machine that is capable of
watching anyone and everyone at will
before we get on to the meat of your
book you know extend that a little bit
you know it's obviously it's reminiscent
I mean now we think of Black Mirror
you know the the British kind of social
media critique show but it's also the
telescreen from 1984 which is both a in
that it's both a mode of propaganda you
can never turn the screen off it's in in
every living room and constantly
muttering and humbly you know while also
taking in stuff you know are we is is
the Dark Mirror different than a tell
screen in that it's you know because
it's the internet on some level that we
are is I mean it's our computer screen
right where were we boot up every day
and surf the web and communicate and
live our lives online and we're just
feeding more information into the
surveillance then right yes but I don't
want to give the misimpression that the
government is watching all of us all the
time
it has set up a system that it's capable
of watching any of us any time and the
way it collects in large volumes of
information it sweeps up many Americans
in some of the programs that aim at
foreigners and once it sweeps us in once
our stuff is captured the government
tends to keep it right and and I mean I
guess we can get into this a little bit
more you know the the people that you
talked at at the NSA and at other
intelligence gathering and law
enforcement agencies are very quick to
say you know we picked this stuff up
where you know it's in a big net it's
incidental it's not our main function
and we're not going to look through that
but we want to keep it because it may
make sense at some point to have those
dots that we can kind of connect later
right I mean the fundamental ultimate
point that they make and I had this
conversation with for example Rick leged
who was deputy director of the NSA said
fundamentally we're not interested in
you you're not that interesting to us I
understand that you're worried about it
but we're just not looking and that is
partly true and partly I think not the
case it is true that we're not the
targets typically unless they get a FISA
warrant a warrant from the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Court they are
not surveilling Americans
deliberately as the aim of their of
their intelligence-gathering but they
are sweeping us in and for some purposes
they do use it for example the
information that is collected from big
US Internet companies under a program
called prism gets poured into a giant
bucket and that's the American stuff as
well as the other stuff and my reporting
found that for every target they collect
they're collecting 10 bystanders many of
those by standards being Americans the
FBI routinely queries that database that
routinely looks through and so for
example the NSA is not allowed by law to
say let me go get NICs communications
but if Knicks communications are swept
up in the mix which is very well
possible the FBI can go into that bucket
and say let's see what you got our NIC
so they call it not targeting for
original surveillance but you can
effectively target by looking into the
into the collection of what's already
been taken you know just as a side note
the book is a phenomenal read it's
almost novelistic in in the best way
possible as journalism and you you
constantly come back to the to the
notion to that metaphors really aren't
that good I mean you know whether it's
like you know a mirror or buckets or
cylinders and things like that and and
it's worth keeping in mind because these
are we're really only getting towards
what is actually going on but you know
talk about prism what what did it do and
where what is it doing is it still
actually operational in the same way as
you were describing it in 2013 prism is
still operational in the same way as
2013 as best anyone knows my information
isn't completely current but there's
been no suggestion that the government
doesn't still value the program which
does produce valuable intelligence and
there's been no legislative effort with
any seriousness oh we explained in
general or you know or give the overview
of how prism operates
prism is this the the government says I
want all the information you have about
person X usually it would be in the form
of an email address or say a Facebook
identifier and then one of the large US
Internet companies and they're all swept
into it whether it's Apple Google
Facebook Microsoft Yahoo and others has
to give over the information so there
may be gigabytes of data about any given
person you can imagine five year history
of your Gmail account
it could have documents photos many many
photos many many documents obviously
tens or hundreds of thousands of emails
all that stuff the government can get it
now it was always true the government
could get that stuff with an individual
warrant what prism did secretly and
without the knowledge of the American
public was allow the NSA to decide for
itself who it wanted to surveil this way
and to do it in very large quantities so
on any given day in 2013 which was the
last day I had access to the information
and it was growing exponentially but any
given did that then there were a hundred
thousand of counsel uncover a hundred
thousand accounts that the NSA was
getting everything in them that's a lot
of targets and because for every account
you get at an average of ten bystanders
that now we're talking about a million
bystanders that are swept into this into
this color this is I mean we can
understand this better now because of
kovat nineteen right or the way the
coronavirus kind of you know every
there's an infection factor so it's
every one person who's there the you
know it extends far outward and you have
a great section where you talk about
hopping and how quickly you know a few
people like we're only looking at a few
people but then we have to look at
everybody around them and suddenly
within a couple of jumps you're talking
about hundreds of thousands of people or
you know practically the entire globe
what who are the
people who are being targeted when you
talk about the hundred thousand who are
they they're supposed to be foreigners
not located in the United States and of
interest on on any of several grounds to
US intelligence community there's no
there's no probable cause there's a
reasonable belief that it's a foreigner
who could produce valuable foreign
intelligence so it could be a terrorist
and that's what they like to talk about
because there's an emotional appeal to
terrorism that's a an emotional appeal
to going after terrorists and it's true
that that targets suspected of terrorism
are an important part of this program
but it's also foreign government
officials foreign corporate officials
people involved in weapons trade all the
usual range of things you would expect
an Intelligence Agency to be interested
in so can you explain how the NSA is not
supposed to be spying on American
citizens particularly or people in
America that's the province of a
different intelligence operation how do
they how do they end up you know kind of
looking at people and things that are in
the United States I well you use the
word earlier and it's a powerful word
it's called incidental collection so
incidental doesn't mean accidental or
unforeseen or even undesirable it just
means that you were aiming for one
person and because of that you swept in
all the people that person communicates
with or about or or isn't it chained
let's suppose there's a foreign
government official who is also
interested in turtles or cooking or
sports cars and isn't if is in a on a
mailing list for people with with that
particular interest all the people on
that list are going to get swept in
because they're in communication with
him and so all of a sudden you're
sitting in Toledo Ohio and you're a car
Susy asked and your communications are
now swept in because they're interested
in the deputy foreign minister of Latvia
talk about muscular that's another
program that you you detailed what is
that well this is the spooky counterpart
of prism because with prism they go
openly in secret I'm talking to people
who are cleared for classified
information they go to Google and say
please hand me everything you've got on
bart and nick and a hundred thousand
other people in the muscular program
they do the collection overseas where
the rules are a lot less strict where
there is no FISA Court surveillance that
it's a supervision congressional
committees get much much less
information about foreign operations and
in the muscular program working with the
GCHQ which is the British counterpart of
the NSA our operators were breaking into
and tapping the private data links that
connect Google Data Centers all around
the world you have to understand that if
you're an American and you're sending an
email from from you to someone down the
street that email is probably going to
end up in Singapore and Bogota because
Google has giant data centers in both of
those places and they distribute the
load globally and they backup globally
and so just because the NSA collects
overseas doesn't mean that it's not
collecting on Americans because the
American stuff is there the internet
doesn't respect geographic boundaries
and so so the NSA was was breaking into
these links it was Google for example as
other companies do has thousands of
miles of privately owned or privately
leased fiber optic cable these connect
these gigantic data centers around the
world and the NSA was breaking into
those in order to not only to collect
lawfully at home according to section
702 of the foreign you know Intelligence
Surveillance Amendments Act but it was
purely executive
purely on the say-so of the president
was breaking in without the knowledge of
Google and taking whatever it liked how
what is the disposition of you go into
this bit of you know Google Yahoo Apple
how do they feel about this because you
know part of them you know are they
willing in what ways are they willing
participants and in what ways are they
kind of dragged into all of this well it
depends on the program and it also
depends on the company and it also
depends on whether you're talking about
before or after the Snowden revelations
all of them went along because they were
obliged by law to go along under the
prison program when they said please
hand over this data here's our court
order authorizing us to get whatever
data we judge to be reasonable then they
pretty much had to comply they would
make sure the order was reasonable in
terms of its framing it they couldn't
say give me the emails of everyone whose
name begins with a B but they had little
choice but to cooperate and at a certain
point they were not they had to
cooperate but they and they were not
allowed to tell anybody what was
requested that was then and you know it
remains true that the these these
requests are classified only a few
people at the company are and are
allowed to know they can't make public
anything about those requests do they
but and that doesn't show up in there
they're kind of annual transparency
documents where they say this many
requests were made of us and this is the
type of information we gave out that was
highly contested and evolving but not
all the information makes its way into
oath transparency reports so so we but I
could just if you don't mind I'll just
finish that answer the the companies
went along with the prism collection
because they had to they didn't know
about until my story they didn't know
about the collection that was going
overseas where there's served their
their data center traffic was being
broken into they were quite outraged by
that and that led to a series of actions
that the companies took and this is sort
of an extraordinary thing American
companies spending tens of millions of
dollars to thwart their own government
surveillance programs were they
successful in that I think there was
considerable success in that but one of
the huge impacts that Snowden had and we
could talk about this later
is that his disclosures led to decisions
by many many companies and eventually
became almost standard on the web to
encrypt their connections to your
computer before Snowden almost all the
browsing you did almost all the email
you sent and received your computer
connected to some big server whether it
was in California or somewhere else
in the clear with an unencrypted line
anyone along the path could just scoop
it all in in high volume and the NSA did
do that now the link to each computer is
can is is encrypted you see the little
padlock icon in your browser bar for
Secure Sockets Layer x' which is the the
encryption method and that has thwarted
high-volume collection to a considerable
extent the NSA can still get anyone they
want to if they decide to target that
person individually but they can't get
everyone as easily anymore so if we take
it back a little bit to get to because I
want to kind of you mentioned before
Snowden or you know and after Snowden I
mean that's it's a huge kind of break
point in the way we talk about all of
this stuff the FISA courts were set up
in the late seventies after you know
really amazingly disturbing revelations
where the most almost the most paranoid
fantasies of you know right-wingers and
left-wingers about government the
government ability or willingness to spy
on just about anybody at any level at
any way came out under the Rockefeller
Commission and the church committee
hearings and whatnot FISA forced first
off it made it clear that the NSA
couldn't be doing stuff on on American
citizens and people in in the country by
after the war on terror sort or after
9:11 walk us through how the Bush
administration originally just kind of
waved away restrictions on you know kind
of limitations on things who was behind
that and then how did it get to a point
where the idea is still though that you
needed a FISA warrant for each target
that you were going after where that
that's then became kind of a mass
program where you just needed a warrant
to say we're gonna be doing this kind of
stuff right so 9/11 happens and there's
an understandable desire on the part of
the US government to not be surprised
again and so there's a huge emphasis on
renewing and expanding collection for
intelligence purposes and that's
laudable I mean they they needed that
information now you know and if I I'm
sorry to interrupt you but you know one
of the things that you make clear and I
think Snowden makes clear and I know
most of the people I know even in the
most kind of anti-surveillance they
people everybody recognizes the need for
government intelligence like Secret
Intelligence and all of that kind of
stuff so it's not a question of whether
or not the government should be able to
investigate people it's it's really more
what are what are the terms of that and
how transparent are they and what are
the limitations but continuing right I
mean that's yeah and I completely agree
with it the transparency is the urgent
thing here you can't have a society in
which the boundaries of intelligence
gathering visa via your own citizens are
secret then the people aren't running
the show yeah
so what happened after 9/11 the best way
to explain it is to take a metaphor or
an image that Michael Hayden who was
then the director of the NSA came up
with he said there's a Venn diagram
right let's you know draw there's and
there's there's three circles one is
here is everything that we would want to
gather if we could it's our wish list
the second circle is here is everything
that were technically capable of
collecting and then the third circle he
said is this is what's lawful this is
what's legal under our current set up
and it's at the intersection of all
three of those circles where we collect
and he gave that briefing to Dick Cheney
the vice president and Cheney looked at
him and he said just suppose you took
that third circle away suppose you
didn't have to worry about what's lawful
tell me everything you could do that
you're not already doing and that was
the genesis of four different domestic
surveillance programs that came into
being without legal authority without
certainly without any explicit court
authority or legislative authority in
the first years after 9/11 and and the
four were these one was essentially
prison the content of internet
communications the word spoken the
images sent the documents the video and
so on another was the content of
telephone calls listening in to the word
spoken and then for each of those two
categories telephone and Internet
there was also metadata collection which
just means data about data it's like the
it's like the outside of the envelope
who it's addressed to who is addressed
from or in a telephone call when did
they talk for how long do they talk
what's the regular pattern of their
conversations and the people that they
talk to who do they talk to you know
contacts of contacts or contacts of
contacts of contacts and and doing big
data network analysis so those were the
four programs in 2000
or there was a crisis because the
Justice Department came to believe that
at least one of those programs was
unlawful and refused to sign off on the
very expansive executive authority that
was claimed by Cheney and his general
counsel David Addington and that led to
a gigantic showdown and very nearly led
to mass resignations from the Justice
Department which was being led on an
acting basis by Jim Comey at the time
and Bush back down there was a gradual
movement after that toward regularizing
these programs toward getting the FISA
Court to authorize them and the FISA
Court made some remarkably broad
findings it agreed in in in litigation
and decisions to positions taken by the
Justice Department that were more
aggressive and frankly more imaginative
than anything that had come before that
and so for example the government had
the authority under the Patriot Act
section 215 to collect quote-unquote
business records that were relevant to
an authorized investigation of terrorism
and the government came to the court and
said we believe that all records of
everyone are relevant because we can use
them for this sort of big data analysis
now relevance is usually in court it's a
it's a legal standard that limits what
you can obtain I can't as civil litigant
in to court and say I want the court to
order that the that the other side
produce all records it's ever had and
also all the other records of all his
competitors and everyone else in the
country just because I might find
something important in there relevant to
me is a confining condition but the
court accepted this frankly outrageous
argument that every phone call made by
every American whether it's local
national or international should be
collected up in terms of its metadata
and they should be able to draw a
gigantic social graph of all of our
communications and then what happened to
you know what happened to limit certain
types or you know what happened that
then changed in the late Bush years and
going into Obama how were these rulings
kind of change or what happened that
then gave rise to what ends up with the
Snowden revelations so at the end of the
Bush years there were several of these
decisions in secret by the FISA Court
now remember that by design the FISA
Court only hears from one side it only
hears from the government and it's
classified so no one on the outside not
only no one can can brief or oppose the
government argument at the time but no
one gets to read the opinion and say
that doesn't make any sense and and
analyze it and so in 2007 and 2008 there
were also legislation passed by Congress
the more important of which was the FISA
Amendments Act which gave the cover of
legal authority to some of the programs
and some of them were never challenged
in court because a people didn't know
about them and B they were taking place
outside the courts authority the FISA
Court does not have jurisdiction over
intelligence operations that take place
overseas that are ostensibly aimed at
foreigners and that's the wiggle room
that that gave the NSA the power and the
practice of bringing in so much
incidental communications that cover so
many Americans so explain or walk us
through how Snowden got in touch with
you originally and you know what was
your sense of him early on because this
is again you know III you know I in a
very serious way I don't want to reduce
your book or your work to kind of
cloak-and-dagger stuff but because it I
mean the content of it is so much more
important than the telling but the
telling is interesting how
how did Snowden contact you well the
cloaca dagger is important to the
narrative because it really is a sort of
real-life spy story and I had to learn
techniques of concealment just in order
to talk to Snowden so I mean when
Snowden first appeared and it was
initially to Laura Poitras the filmmaker
he was an anonymous individual named
veer axe which I had to look up it's
Latin for truth teller and by the way it
was meant to be a little bit of a
contrast to Julian Assange she would had
at one point used that handle Mendes
and he said he was a member of the
intelligence community with a gigantic
scoop about a scandal in terms of
overreach of surveillance and to be
honest my first reaction was oh no not
this again because if you're a reporter
and especially a national security
reporter there is no end of conspiracies
that come in to your inbox and most of
them are cranks or they're fakers or
they're sincere believers in something
but they don't understand it and this
was a lesson in humility for me because
my first thought was that this was
likely to be a false alarm I almost told
that to Laura Poitras but I bit my
tongue and heard her out and I'm glad I
did because every time we tested this V
rax character and asked more questions
the answers came back more than
plausible and he had one habit which I
found especially persuasive and that is
to say I don't know there were lots of
questions we asked that he said I'm not
an expert in that or I don't I don't
have that information I have this
information if you want I can make some
informed speculation but it's only
speculation that's confidence-building
as was
the fluent way he spoke the language of
intelligence the language of network
communications the the language of NSA
programs and also the way he sort of
slipped into it without even really
quite realizing that he had gone from
English to jargon that's common in
people who work in closed systems and
it's actually kind of hard to fake so I
had endless I mean dozens of hours of
communications with Snowden before I
knew his name just trying to establish
his bona fides are you for real do you
have any ground to know what you're
talking about and this is before I've
seen any of his documents either so far
all of this is about I've got a secret
that I'm gonna tell you but not yet he
was meanwhile trying to establish my
bona fides did he believe that I as a
mainstream journalist would have the
guts to publish a story if he gave it to
me that he did he believed that the
Washington Post was going to cave in to
pressure from the government to squelch
this story to me those questions had
obvious answers but they weren't obvious
to him I mean while we're doing all this
communication through these spooky
channels we're bouncing our
communications all over the world to
anonymize them we're using encryption
we're using short-lived accounts and
then switching to other accounts I'm
using burner computers and disguising
their MAC addresses and their IP
addresses and everything we could
possibly do to try to basically sneak up
on a surveillance machine without being
surveilled would you talk a bit about
because you you were working at the
Century Foundation you had been at the
Washington Post you were no longer there
and when you got this story and you
realize that it was true you also had a
relationship with Time magazine and you
went to them with the opportunity to for
that to be the outlet it didn't work out
there it did at the Washington Post
could you could you discuss a little bit
the difference of the receptions at
those you know these are two great
legacy media kind of outlets one
was like yeah you know what we're not
going to go there and the other one was
yeah we're we're going with you well the
sad truth is that Time magazine which is
under new new ownership now but at the
time it was part of the Time Warner
Empire and Time magazine did exactly
what Snowden feared the mainstream media
would do is it it it didn't have to wait
to cave into government pressure it was
afraid that text the story in the first
place no maybe nothing to me that's you
know as a journalist and as somebody
who's a columnist that time for a while
I was like wow that explains why time
you know in in a profound way no longer
matters because it blinked when given
the opportunity to pursue one of the one
of the most important stories you know
certainly of the post warrior certainly
of the 21st century the post Cold War in
it but in American history what what do
you think drove their there on you know
their lack of curiosity or their or
their fear well I should emphasize in
fairness that I worked with and for some
really great journalists who had all the
right instincts they wanted to go ahead
but the corporate bosses we're thinking
of a spinoff they were gonna get rid of
Time magazine and the whole magazine
division because it was a drag on their
fabulous profits in the in for example
the film in the theme park industry so
the corporate bosses were afraid of a
litigation risk they were afraid of the
Espionage Act they were afraid of the
controversy that might affect regulatory
decisions they just sort of saw nothing
in it for them to go forward like this
and they never said I absolutely refuse
to run this story they simply told me
that I would have to operate under rules
in which for example I couldn't talk to
the editors about my story because it
was classified and I would have to only
talk to some outside law firm which had
a cleared lawyer who would tell me what
was fit to print and what wasn't and
then I could talk about that with I mean
it was it was
lately so Ananse all right it's kind of
the difference and we'll get to the post
in a second but a time was no longer or
at least at the time you were
interacting with was no longer primarily
a journalism organization it was
something else well you know it was but
it was bound yeah it was limited yeah
so then you're you know one of the one
of the heroes of your of your book
really is Marty Baron who has emerged at
you know in multiple places as one of
the great you know kind of stiff spine
irons spined
you know journalists editors of you know
the past decades
what was your experience at the post my
experience at the post was very
different look I had been at the
Washington Post for 21 years
as you mentioned I had left the post in
2010 and gone to work at the Century
Foundation working on magazine and book
projects when I got this Snowden leak
I mean first one document and then
50,000 highly classified documents I did
not want to be freelance Bart trying to
cope with this I needed I needed the
legal cover and the resources and the
partnerships of a large news
organization to to work with this so
after time I went to back to my old
employer the Washington Post Marty Baron
was relatively new as the editor I had
never met him I knew him by reputation
he led the coverage in Boston of the you
know Catholic Church child abuse scandal
which was a brave thing to do in Boston
in particular given the demographics
there he had a great reputation but I
didn't know him from Adam and I I called
up an editor I didn't know at the post
and said hi it's Bart I need a meeting
with the top boss right away I can't
tell you why which didn't really go over
very well so now you're like V racks
kind of going I've got the greatest
story in the world but I can't really
tell you anything about it let me talk
well I didn't want to talk about it
you know I wanted to talk about it in
Persia and I wanted to talk about it
with the with the man who could make a
decision this there are various points
that I I don't know if you've seen it I
don't know if anybody watching or
listening has but they should there's a
great movie from the 70s called the
parallax view with Warren Beatty as an
investigative reporter who's looking
into the murder the assassination of a
senator and he you know he comes off as
a crazy person but of course he he's
actually right about everything but I'm
sorry to interrupt my diet well I was
like getting you to Warren Beatty so
that's how I have to enjoy it very much
yeah I'm always happy if you like until
I start I well I did come off as a great
person I mean there's a scene in the
book in which I finally have gathered
the lawyers and Marty Baron and a couple
of his top leaders from the newsroom and
we're in a windowless conference room
and I ask everyone to please take their
mobile phones and either remove the
battery search or yeah take them out of
the room yeah please here as in foil
hats secure them yes I yeah I mean I
write in the book that it they reacted
as though I had asked them to peel off
their socks it just made no sense to
them well you know and this comes up a
couple of times in the book you know
this was at a moment when it wasn't
clear that your cell phones could be you
it could be you could be worked operated
remotely as listening devices and things
like that and I can remember the first
times I heard the first time I heard
people talking about that it was like
okay I got a you know there's a train I
got a catch to get as far away from the
person telling me that as possible but
you know there it is it turns out that
that is true yeah the NSA has the
capability remotely to turn on your
microphone and you won't know yeah
and I I just didn't know what I was up
against who I was up against at the time
I didn't expect the NSA to be doing
rogue operations against an American
journalist but honestly an authorized
counterintelligence operation might have
been legally available to them in if
they if they knew what was going on and
I also knew that as soon as foreign
governments got wind that I had a lot of
classified American documents that I
would become interesting to them as well
as and it will as sophisticated hackers
who just wanted to look at the documents
for fun or profit so we didn't take
extraordinary precautions and and my
introduction to Marty Baron is me
telling this guy who's never met me that
if we're gonna be able to work together
he's gonna have to build a safe room you
know get a big heavy safe remove the
guts of computer networking hardware
from the computers we use master new
forms of encryption etc etc and I listen
to myself talking and I thought he was
gonna throw me out yeah they really did
and uh you reminded me in those moments
of in there's an episode of Seinfeld
when George and Jerry are pitching a
pilot to NBC and George just starts
making categorical demands you know
non-negotiable demands like this is the
show and we're not gonna dumb it down
Freddie would but but it works I mean
you get I was absolutely Georgia yes an
area uh but it worked
Marty said okay we can agree to those
conditions let's talk about the story so
you you know in the in the book you one
of the things and and it's clear Snowden
was he was talking to different types of
people and Laura Poitras you know and
now an Academy award-winning
documentarian but a very highly regarded
filmmaker who had run afoul of the
government with earlier work
particularly about Iraq and weapons of
mass destruction Glenn Greenwald a
little bit later on at the Guardian you
know part of what he needed really in a
lot of ways was somebody like you who
is working in mainstream media you know
that is also you know has a credibility
that's something like The Guardian the
British Guardian was not necessarily
going to bring you you are not
uncritical of Edward Snowden but in the
book you say that you trusted him yet
there were a couple of times where he
clearly had kind of patted his resume so
to speak what you know what were the
things where he overstated what he had
actually done or what he had in his
possession and why did you trust him so
much well first of all I trusted that I
could verify the documents and the
documents were my primary source not
Snowden himself
I didn't rely on him to explain to me
what the programs were and I quoted him
in very few stories and and only about
himself as I said he had earned my trust
by by cabining his answers to things
that he knew about and telling me what
he didn't know and I was able to verify
some of what he said and the documents
very verified a lot of what he said but
there were times when he exaggerated he
wanted to make sure that I would believe
him he wanted to qualify himself he had
a sense that the jobs he had been
assigned in the intelligence community
did not comport with his abilities he is
one of the smartest people I've ever met
I mean IQs off the charts self educated
and believed he was capable of far more
than the jobs he was given and so he did
exaggerate those jobs I mean there's a
there's a point in one of his resumes he
he talks about being you know a sort of
a computer contractor at Fort Meade
which turned out to be a teenage job
helping run a hobbyist website that was
out of the basement of an apartment on
Fort Meade not working for the US
government and then he also he claimed
that he had listened in
the gang of eight people doing
immigration reform as well as members of
the Supreme Court that turned out to be
an exaggeration as well that's true
that's the the biggest the biggest thing
he ever told me that turned out to be
untrue was that in order to prove that
any analyst could listen in on anyone he
had deliberately breached the rules
listened to the eight senior most
leaders in Congress and listened to and
and and also surveilled the justices of
the Supreme Court turned out that that
didn't happen and I finally got him to
admit it two years after the fact but I
never published it either because I
needed backup and he never could give me
the backup so I'm I'm honest in the book
I mean I'm I think I give a rounded
picture of Snowden yeah I think so in
many ways I admire and and he has a he
has human flaws now you you also talked
to throughout the book you mentioned
this on a number of occasions people
like kind of rank-and-file employees at
the NSA in other places you say you know
every every time you looked you found
them scrupulous ly trying to comply with
the letter of the law as well as in most
cases the spirit of the law and yet they
were involved in programs that just
seemed to be off the charts in terms of
you know if not being strictly illegal
or unconstitutional just really bad and
then you when you talk to the leadership
do you know the James clapper is the
Keith Alexander's of the world them the
Michael Hayden's they're really
squirrely about you know whether or not
they should be bound by any rules or or
that you and I mean you're an informed
civilian I mad I'm an uninformed
civilian relatively like we don't
understand we never could understand so
they don't really feel a need to be
fully honest with us is that true and
and then how do you how do you put that
all together to figure out you know
where where we should be heading with
this kind of stuff
well first of all in medical Kinsley's
great phrase sometimes the scandal is
what's legal run you could be following
the letter of the law and it's
interpreted secretly in such a way that
it can do remarkable things remarkable
things that the American public if it
knew about them would not approve but no
I never said it was illegal because
there was no one there to challenge it
in court because it was a secret or
because the foreign intelligence court
only heard from the government so there
was a great deal that was legal as it
was then interpreted some of it Congress
has since made it illegal and some of it
when it finally because of Snowden got
heard by a regular title 3 of the
Constitution federal court a judge found
to be unconstitutional was the biggest
thing that was you know that is not
happening now because of these Snowden
revelations the biggest thing is the
collection of all those telephone
records of all the Americans that
program not only was found to be of
dubious constitutional validity courts
split on that but Congress changed the
program and effectively outlawed it and
not only that but even the way that it
was eventually allowed to continue the
NSA decided was not worth doing because
it had not produced much of anything
that was the great metadata tutorial
right of two thousand thirteen and
fourteen I guess that's when that's what
a lot of us first heard the term
metadata and and began to understand its
power yeah what were the stories you
chose not to tell I mean because this is
you have you know a almost infinite
amount of material but you talk about
this as those portraits and Greenwald
you you didn't tell everything there you
didn't publish everything and there's I
think you know you'd mentioned Julian
Assange before one of the things that
many people hold up
they hold Snowden higher regard because
he went to journalists who then were
discriminant in what they published what
are how did you make the decision of
this as a story we need to bring out to
the public and this is something that
we're not gonna pursue well first of all
there are a lot of things in the archive
that just aren't interesting as news
stories that aren't they they don't
raise important public policy questions
they don't raise questions of boundaries
there's nothing to deal with corruption
or overreach or wasteful spending or or
anything that's legally controversial
and so just giving out technical
information about how the NSA does its
job if you believe in the value of
intelligence at all it's it's just
nothing but harm it's not a close call
there other cases where the story would
be significant I mean it's it's
noteworthy news but if you tell the
story you're going to immediately blow
an operation that's productive against
someone who just about anyone would
acknowledge is a legitimate adversary
hostile to this nation's interests so
let's suppose they find specific
evidence of a breach of nuclear weapons
treaty in some country and you say they
found out about this breach by the
following means well they're not going
to have that means anymore the bad actor
the adversary is going to learn how to
conceal and those are stories that I
wasn't interested in in publishing I
mean so they could be fantastic
sensational stories I mean I I can't
really say what the stories were that I
held back so I come up with a sort of a
fanciful so some of them are boring and
not interesting and others are too big
to really reveal well others others get
into very specific targets and very
specific channels of of surveillance I
mean here's my fanciful illustration
let's let's suppose that I
I find out one day that the NSA has
invented mind-reading gearing's and has
placed them on the mistress of the
Emperor of Mars and by this means has
detected the plans to invade the earth
and thwarted it you would say holy moly
that's one of the stories of the century
that's humongous and a reader would read
the story and say wow that's a big deal
I'm sure glad that they stopped that
plot and now you son of a [ __ ] they
can't stop the next one because you just
told everyone how they did it on the
other hand if the NSA produced
mind-reading technology that would be a
fairly big and important thing to debate
because it has pretty significant civil
liberties implications as well so you
might not talk about the earrings of the
Emperor's mistress on Mars but you might
want to say the NSA is developing
mind-reading technology and it raises
all these questions and it's being done
in secret I'm also worried if we can get
to Mars when we're still wearing
earrings I don't know it's it seems like
uneven progress need to work on then a
few minutes left I want to ask a couple
of questions about the continuity of the
willingness of the intelligence
community to kind of push and circumvent
and hide an obscure and obfuscate from
the public you know we were we are
taught to believe that George W Bush was
awful in a particular way some of us
think Obama was awful in a particular
way many of us believe Donald Trump is
awful yet more awful in different ways
is there a continuity though among
people in the intelligence community
that you know Obama and and you have one
of his one of his advisers saying you
know like we would be you or when Obama
said this actually when the son self
came out like oh I welcome you know a
conversation about national you know
surveillance and all of national
security and all of that kind of stuff
but it never seems to happen unless
somebody pushes it from the outside is
it safe to say that there's a logic to
the intelligence community that
runs cleanly through whatever
administration whether they're liberal
or conservative whether they're
democratic or republican and they're
just gonna do what they're gonna do or
get away with as much as possible Hayden
has that you know metaphor about
dirtying the lines like really working
you know the the in you know the line
that's out of bounds you know it is
there a continuity there that escapes
any kind of partisanship that's
meaningful I think there is a continuity
the continuity is first of all the
intelligence community wants to protect
the country and wants to obtain the
information that the president and the
president's people say they need I need
to know what the economic plans are in
China I need to know what the real
fallback negotiating position is of this
rival in a set of bilateral or
multilateral talks I need to I need to
get to yes so tell me what he's really
willing to give up there's a whole long
list of literally thousands of items of
interest that guides intelligence
community behavior and they also know
that there is ZERO tolerance for failure
that if you miss something big another
9/11 or something even as relatively
small as one guy with with explosives in
his shoe getting it on an airplane
you're gonna be blamed and so of course
they want to use every tool they could
possibly get of course they are going to
push the rules the this Hayden's image
was that he wants to play the game with
chalk on his cleats he wants to be right
on that line and if you're allowed to
define in secret where the line is it
might not be a line that others would
accept or that Outsiders would accept so
yeah there's a continuity in that all
the all the institutional incentives are
toward more more intelligence gathering
and more secrecy can I ask with you know
the presidential election is essentially
between Joe Biden and Donald Trump you
asked a lot of the heads of our former
heads of intelligence services you know
are you comfortable work you know that
Donald Trump is now getting to call the
shots given the way that you yourselves
operated
in many gray if not absolutely black
areas you know how did they respond to
that and then also Joe Biden was vice
president under Barack Obama who was
really bad on journalists who were
trying to expose the national
surveillance state and who was a faker
or an obfuscator on a lot of what was
going on in his watch you know how do
people respond about the donald trump
question and do you think is joe biden
some is he an apostle of transparency in
any meaningful way interesting questions
well first of all with regard to trump
you have to rewind a little bit
when snowden raised the question whether
we could trust government with these
enormous powers members of the
intelligence community thought that was
obvious they trusted themselves they
trusted each other they trusted the
rules they knew that their actual
motives were to protect the country and
so they thought why would anybody
challenge this when they look at the
same programs under the auspices of
donald trump someone who is no respecter
of rules or traditions someone who can't
be relied on to tell the truth I mean
can be relied on to lie every day of his
presidency they're much less sanguine
about the government accumulating this
enormous machinery of surveillance it is
subject to horrific potential abuse I
mean we're we're living in a world where
within living memory we had J Edgar
Hoover and Richard Nixon and flatly
illegal surveillance programs and those
things could return so they're they're
surprisingly thoughtful
I think I'm not surprised they're
thoughtful they're they're surprisingly
willing to make concessions about their
doubts about programs they had taken for
granted for their whole careers and I
have you know several long scenes in the
book of conversation with Jim clapper
who was the director of national
intelligence who shows fresh doubts in
the book about those programs
Joe Biden no he's not been an apostle of
transparency in the in the national
security world he was a strong backer of
the prosecution of whistleblowers and
leakers in the Obama administration and
there were more prosecutions with
charges of espionage against people who
talk to journalists during the Obama
administration than in all previous
administrations combined which had a
chilling effect on national security
reporting at the same time you can't
claim that they shut down national
security reporting or anything like that
because to be honest in the time since
9/11 there have been more huge
revelations about secret programs then
at any other time in journalistic
history Barr Kelvin thank you so much
for talking to reason the book is dark
mirror read it with the lights on thanks
Bart Gellman thank you very much
pleasure being here